you ever flown on spirit before you know
you're kind of like I have but I don't
want to tell anybody you know the
airline that you go on you pay 55 bucks
and you're like oh this is nothing check
in the back 55 bucks 55 bucks can I get
a you WiFi $7 $12 can I you get some
food $15 wait a minute it's the same as
the other guys but still Market wise
spirit is known for being the cheapest
out there to the point where the
industry average margins are 2.6% plus
profit 2.6% the last 2 years Spirit
minus 8 1/2% this last year year before
minus 11% they're not making any money
so recently they wanted to do a merger
with Jet Blue and guess who stopped the
merger from taking place the US
government you might be asking why
here's why so Spirit Airlines faces
uncertainty after an Anti-Trust ruling
blocked its sale to JetBlue for $3.8
billion a federal judge in Boston
concurred with the justice department
citing consumer harm through reduced
choices and increased fairs so the judge
sounds like he's coming from a noble
place we don't want Spirit to go away
because Let's help him right from the
moment he says this the judge this is on
the 16th here's what happens to the
spirit stock it plummeted by over half
since the ruling prompting consideration
of debt refinancing its shares closed
Thursday at
$5.70 down more than 60% from the
previous week and by the way they have a
loan due in September of 2025 this is a
1.1 billion loan at 8% which by the way
this whole thing that corporate debt
corporate debt corporate debt is coming
out so they were going to buy him for
$3.8 billion you know what Spirits
market cap is today give or take
$680 million you know what they were
worth November of 2014 over $6 billion
the judge is thinking they're helping
them but you may have forced this
company to bankruptcy who does that help
we're going to talk about that today if
you value of this video give it a thumbs
up and subscribe to the channel by the
way another reason why capitalism works
and it doesn't when the government gets
involved in situations like this you
know how many airlines we have you're
worried about spirit and Jet flu working
together you effectively hurt the
company you judge you you did that you
hurt this company let them do their part
but watch this what situation they're in
Jet Blue spirit's financial situation is
very messy their debt surged to $6.6
billion from only $3.6 billion in 2019
this is preo and keep in mind when the
airlines all of a sudden had to Flat de
if you look at the chart to see how many
flights was taking place in a year
you'll see the sudden drop off in 2020
they all got crushed you see the p with
number of passengers carried through
Spirit Airlines from 2003 to 2002 look
at the 2020 year but everybody looks
like that right but generally they went
from 2003 only having 4 million people
to 2019 33 million even 2022 they went
back up to 38 million but in that year
2020 the government came in and said
let's bail out these airline companies
watch this we looked at the map what
these Airlines did Topline revenue and
how much they got bailed out by the US
government and then we did the
calculation of what the percentage of
money they got compared to their Topline
Revenue here's what it looked like at
the top Southwest Airlines got roughly
133% so for example if Southwest
Airlines Topline revenue is give or take
23 $24 billion Southwest Airlines got
roughly $3.3 billion from the US
government give or take 133% right you
see how we did the formula then second
place is American Airlines 12% then
third place is Jet Blue also 12% tied
with American Airlines Delta got 10% but
guess how much Spirit got when they were
bailing out all these airline companies
ready only 6.4% so meaning they could
have got another $150 million but they
didn't get it so only save the too big
to fail let's Spirit go out of business
while closely to 40 million people use
Spirit every single year I remember not
having money and leaning on airlines
like this and it's necessary for low and
middle income families to go visit their
families but the government is
potentially causing a company like
spirit that we all make fun of and we've
all secretly used or currently use to go
away as an option for you as the cons
consumer now let me continue they
recently reduced their debt by selling
and leasing back 25 of their jets for
$465 million meanwhile on top of that
the airline is currently struggling
because the problems they have with the
Pratt and Whitney engines on some of its
planes Spirit grounded 26 of its nearly
200 Jets after the supplier disclosed
manufacturing defects meanwhile Spears
labor costs are rising as the airline
and its Pilots Last year agreed on a new
contract ready that will boost Pilot's
pay by an average of
34% over its 2-year term and just in the
third quarter spear lost nearly $158
million a period that included much of
the peak summer travel season with the
company siding softer demand and
discounted fairs now meanwhile here's
what you got to be thinking about
because industry experts are saying the
following they're saying number one
either spirit is going to be acquired by
another airline which by the way if
you're one of the big Airlines you're
thinking that judge and you're saying
hey judge thank you you just saved us a
billion dollar or half a billion dollar
or maybe $2 billion and option number
two what industry experts are saying
it's going to happen ready bankruptcy
because what are you going to do if you
keep losing money every single year and
everything going up and planes are being
shut down and on top of that guess what
else is going on with boink or Airbus if
you want to order some planes you ready
for this watch this they have a backlog
of orders that stretches out as far as 5
years if you call boing right now saying
hey I need 20 boing Jets you know what
it'll tell you we got a 5year walk think
about that so even if they wanted to
invest and grow they're not going to get
those planes for nearly 5 years why
should you care about this because you
know how you and I win the more
competition there is the better it is
for you and I Starbucks Coffee Bean you
go to 7-Eleven maybe you go to the dut
Place whatever it's called maybe you go
to this other place you have options so
they got to compete to have the best
coffee for you cars you got options you
got a lot of things that are options but
notice with banks the bigger guys are
gradually buying the smaller guys we're
getting fewer and fewer Banks notice
also when it comes down to these
military contractors used to be 50
something now you're really dealing with
five of them that you're buying stuff
from and then watch what's going on with
Airlines this is from 1995 to today in
1995 you had 85 carriers you were
dealing with with 11 being major
carriers but look what's increasing and
look what's decreasing other air
carriers have decreased from 85 to 44
but notice the major air carriers have
increased from 11 to 19 why because the
11 are buying up everybody else and the
other guys that used to be 85 down to 44
they're going out of business because
with the help of great lobbyists
fantastic right these lobbyist you hire
and guess what you want to do with
lobbyist not that any of these guys
would ever do something like this I'm
sure this industry is fulled with many
noble people but you help by making the
barrier the entry you know for the other
smaller guys to compete just enough
business a little bit to be happy about
it then boom crisis happens they go out
of business we buy them on discount we
buy them on discount we buy them on this
account boom boom boom boom boom boom
and then all of a sudden you're one of
the Behemoth companies out there
gigantic that they can't do anything to
allow you to go out of business because
you are too big to fail I want to show
you two other events that took place
that hurt the airline industry one of
them being the labor unions what they
did in 2023 two major events happened
one of them was September 29th 2023
which United Pilots won 40% raise as
Union ratifies new contract which means
whatever they do that's pretty much the
precedent the standard for everybody
else to follow so other Airline captains
are going to come out and Pilots are
going to say hey United did this you got
to do this for us as well smaller guys
are forced to do so sometimes they can't
American Airlines Pilots also approved a
new contract giving more than 15,000
Pilots immediate 21% raise total
compensation increase of more than
46% over the course of a 4-year contract
and then Southwest Airlines Pilots also
got about a 50% pay raise over a 5-year
period in their new contract and by the
way the reason why I'm giving you those
numbers first is because when you think
about their operational expenses 31% of
it is labor 31% of Labor counts for
their operational expenses fuel is 22%
you may have said fuel would have been
higher no look at the difference between
oil and the kind of money they used to
make so look at prices of oil what it
was like from 2010 the highs of 160 to
2020 as low as $25 if you see those
chart now go look at the profits on iida
from 2010 to 2020 and focus mainly on
purple because purple is North America
you see how North America in 2015
they're making margins of 15% ebit of
15% 2016 roughly 133% 27 they're making
money right 2019 is still good then
Watch What Happens 20 postco drop okay
minus
30% for North America 2021 drop 2022
back up 2023 slightly back up at around
2.6% but not for companies like Spirit
they haven't had a chance to recover
from what happened during the pandemic
and the oil prices constantly changing
now here's what drives a lot of people
nuts you know there were the PPP loans
they give roughly $25 billion to all
these airline companies during the time
400,000 people were fired but at the
same time what do they do with 90% of
the money that was given to them you
know what these airline industry these
companies did they use 96% of the money
you gave them to buy back shares
wonderful what's the moral the story
industry Airline industry's margins are
this thin very small these airlines that
don't charge a lot for their tickets
they're not making money you want these
businesses to stay in business every
time I go to Barnes & Noble we buy
$1,000 worth of stuff at Barnes & Noble
and I ask to cashier he sees me every
time and he knows what question I'm
going to ask how how are your numbers
looking are you guys making money why
cuz I want Barnes and Noble to stay in
business you probably want Spirit to
stay business but to do so they're going
to have to increase their prices a
little bit and the US government's got
to kind of stay out of the way because
what Monopoly law here you got all these
other airlines why are you worried about
Spirit you could allow these guys to do
business together them and JetBlue but
you keep getting in their way and the
judge whether it's intentional or not
they're either going to make him go out
of business or be Buy
on sale even more discounted than what
Frontier and JetBlue offered them if you
got value out of this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
if you don't know the story of what
unions do to America maybe you are also
part of a union you want to learn more
click here to watch the video you're
either going to get very upset you're
going to say oh my God it's crazy what
these guys doing how much power they got
anyways take care everybody bye-bye
bye-bye